yes we want someone to go through a
rigorous set of online courses with us
get a credential goes through a bootcamp
get a credential and then we want to
create an apprenticeship opportunity and
have the person go spend three to six
months at the United Nations and you
know perhaps FIFA a start-up and advisor
at at a university being an apprentice
to two person who is on the cutting edge
and and that in its own right then
becomes a credential - and your pathway
to a new opportunity in in your vocation
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to still be at MIT in
Cambridge in Massachusetts we are now
going to be talking about new pathways
in education we have our Dean Mishima of
joining us on the show hello so much
pleasure being with you I'm super
excited and I'm very grateful to Sanjay
Sarma for introducing us that was also
an incredible episode at MIT xopen
Learning Center I love this place you
guys are doing incredible work and for
those who don't know or Dean's
background he's the founder and director
of MIT boot camps MIT X micro masters
co-created mi t--'s first mooc on
entrepreneurship and is a lecturer at
MIT he's passionate about building a
world where there are no barriers
between motivation and opportunity and
you can find her Dean's links below
let's start things off with our favorite
question we love asking we find
ourselves as stewards of earth what is
your current take on the state of
humanity it's a wonderful question to
ask but an important one I think the
current zeitgeist is one of anxiety
humanity has reached an impasse on a
number of levels we are concerned about
the effects of Technology on the world
and for for the last few decades we've
lived with the idea that technology is a
friend of humanity and I think this idea
is beginning to show cracks in fact
serious serious cracks and so we as
humans are anxious we are anxious
because we don't have the answers today
and so the the current zeitgeist is one
of anxiety and the current mission is
one of finding finding the answers I
also think we have built building
various forms of managing our global
society right the the 20th century was a
century of wars but it was also a
century of building international
organizations that can prevent future
Wars but now we see the departure from
that model we see a breaking a part of
vital international organizations now my
view of this is our existing structures
are if not collapsing but weakening not
because you know people are bad and they
don't want them but because perhaps they
are not answering the present realities
the present challenges and so I think
the challenge is upon us to invent new
structures to imagine new ways of being
yelled amantha I wonder if every single
time period like hundred years ago a
thousand years ago that they were
constantly thinking oh this is such a
challenging time to be alive we have so
many problems to tackle but we do have
all the exponential technology happening
today which makes it obviously but
they're different than than in the past
and I think we can do it especially with
Millennials and Gen Z I have a lot of
faith in our ability to do things like
tackle these these challenges let's do
the journey so from Kyrgyzstan to the
University of Bradford in the United
Kingdom to Harvard and then to MIT teach
us about how you even you know got the
the courage and the and to the
motivation to leave home and to go
pursue your career well I appreciate you
you you're asking this and being
interested I think the simple answer is
one of angels you know everybody needs
angels I was in Kyrgyzstan as you know
as a teenager and my world seemed very
small and
I think when it when it feels this way
you want to open up and when you want to
expand your world but how do you do that
it's it's it's not it's not so easy and
it just so happened that in our home
town there was a center established by
George Soros
a well known financier and
philanthropist and he opened the network
of what he called open society centers
where you could go and it offered the
library that was free and you can read
books in English you could study English
you could read about universities in
other countries and so I would just
spend a little bit of time there and
then also I began attending a university
in in carry school Callison called the
American University in Cairo Stan I
didn't graduate from it I ended up
graduating from college in in the United
Kingdom but that university was started
with the idea of bringing liberal arts
education to the former Soviet Union and
we had American and European academics
going and teaching there and the as I
reflect on them now they had this
fabulous dedication to teaching and so
they got me inspired
they got me inspired by learning they
got me inspired by but learning
something that young people like me in
our country couldn't ordinarily study
before political science and study the
liberal thinkers that was that was a
novelty and so I got impassioned by that
and won a scholarship to to Bradford but
again yeah to the topic of angels yes I
did win a scholarship
did I work very hard I did but did I get
lucky in some respects of course of
course somebody on the other end at
Bradford University had to review my
scholarship application and you know
they had to be having a good day and
they had to say you know I want to I
want to see something here I want you
know I want to trust this person who's
because behind this application and so I
think the the journey is one of working
hard and then taking a chance but also
angels you know and everyone's lives are
angels and down I've had I've been very
lucky it was a fair share of mine in my
life and then you're pointing at the
really important these these different
stimuli that can be such crucial to
altering the trajectory and Max
the potential of people and like the
Resource Center that was a be made
available to you and then all of the the
next steps that you took the doors that
you saw and that you seize those
opportunities and you kept going this is
a reoccurring theme of the people that
we sit down with this is exactly that
then how about we do this this journey
when you get to this MIT Sloan School of
Management okay and so then you're
you're figuring out that like open
learning is very interesting and you
want to you ended up being the
co-founder and director then of of mi
t--'s boot camps MIT X's micro masters
this is I mean this is all like this is
all really cool stuff and it's all open
which is so interesting - yeah you know
it it's a journey that's been long in
the making when I first when I first
came to Cambridge Massachusetts from
Bradford I actually came to a conference
with the idea of perhaps applying here
for graduate school and I remember the
day that I walked into old yard and you
know at Harvard I remember clear as day
and at that time and you know we didn't
have cell phones that we could take
pictures with so the sort of the
recollection of the moment is is here
and here only I remember it clear as day
and I remember this sense of
intellectual vibrancy yes yeah you could
you could feel it it was an amazing
feeling and I asked myself how is it
that only a few students in the world
those are here in Cambridge in in
schools at Harvard MIT have the
opportunity of access to to this
wonderful stuff and why don't kids and
kyrgystan my home country have it too
that was really a question that was on
my mind literally the moment I walked in
and so when I later came to school at
MIT I actually started sort of [ __ ]
running and gunning I would have a
camera and I would go to different labs
and take little interviews but at the
time there was nowhere to put it there
was no platform where you can you can
achieve visibility with the content
you're creating and so I graduated from
MIT I ended up founding a company then
and to a venture capital firm but then
suddenly things changed I call it the
second revolution online education we
saw the emergence of new educational
platforms Udacity Coursera then MIT and
Harvard joined forces and established
the decks and I realized that that was a
moment I had to go back to MIT to be a
part of this revolution so I left the
venture firm came to MIT and began
creating online courses because now now
which is was what was different from
when I was a student you know with my
own camera and my friends in different
labs here there was a place to
distribute your videos online and reach
a lot of people and have impact the
being able to see that why is this such
a strong knodel cluster of intelligence
and creativity and access to the tools
that let you build the future and why is
it not yet democratized to other places
around the world and then yeah actually
having the platforms to be able to put
the content on to enable people around
the world just a computer an internet
connection to be able to pursue that
kicked in and then you're able to really
unleash that so then yeah so then tell
us about how you ended up picking up to
be able to take all of the content
you're learning here at MIT and putting
it up to for distribution oh yeah my
thought was relatively straightforward I
ask myself well what professors did I
enjoy during my time as student here who
did I benefit the most from and who do I
think people around the world would
benefit from as well and the first
person was Bill oullette he was my
mentor at MIT he was the head of an
entrepreneurship Center and I just knew
that he had to be heard by the pronounce
worldwide and so I went to him and I
said bill can we create a version of
your course for entrepreneurs at MIT for
entrepreneurs around the world it's
great and we did it the course was
called the entrepreneurship 101 who is
your customer and we wanted to teach
aspiring entrepreneurs one of the most
important learning journeys for any
and that is to begin seeing the world
through the eyes of the customer and the
preneur saw idea-driven people tend to
be and so it is very easy for them to
see the world through through their own
eyes and then there is nothing wrong
with that you actually want them because
you want to have a person with a vision
but that also has the flipside
that the vision can take over the
reality and you have to play with some
balance that was a goal of the course we
worked very hard
there were many sleepless nights but I
remember that they would launch the
course and in in iudex in the course
management - we had a dashboard that
tells you how many students I am rolling
and I was amazed how that dashboard
ticker kept rolling and by by the end of
the course we had more than 60,000
students in if the first yeah in the
first instance people want to know about
entrepreneurship people want to know
about how to start ideas execute ideas
yeah they do they do and that's because
so I that's what I realized through that
experience I I sense that I had a hunch
that yes the the passion that I have
found the preneur shop is not is not a
unique passion I think it is something
that we many of us share and I think if
we go back to kind of the to be more
established or kind of historical roots
of human society were all entrepreneurs
right we're all small business owners
before the emergence of very complex
societies in which I live today so I
think that's natural and what I realized
in the course that was fundamental to me
I realized that people want to be
entrepreneurs that because they want to
be rich that's what I think one would be
apt to think by by following
entrepreneurship through the eyes of
popular media I don't think that's the
answer I think people want to be
entrepreneurs because I want to be
independent it's not wealth its
independence its independence of
worldview its independence of action and
you know if it bring and obviously
sometimes that's correlated with some
economic independence
but economic independence and and
welfare correlated they're not the same
they're not the same and so as soon as I
discovered that I think my my
professional world view changed
dramatically yeah yeah I ideas getting
executed is a lot for us finding some
sort of a meaning in life as well we can
that waking up every morning and wanting
to build the thing that we came up with
and wanting to work on that is something
that drives so much meaning and yeah it
gives us that independence especially
that free thinking like you're saying
that's so critical economic freedoms
very critical
yeah and that that's crazy that MOOC
that you started on entrepreneurship now
has hundreds of thousands of people it
has 65 countries something know all
countries in all all countries in the
world with all the countries we have
students from every country in the world
okay it's boot camps that has the the
sixty-five I think or something like
that yeah I'm very happy to share about
that yes let's do that so that's crazy
that the Entrepreneurship course has
been just blowing up like that I love it
that means there's gonna be lots more
ideas executed yeah let's hit boot camps
this is interesting you guys actually
just had are you or you have a couple
that are coming up over the summer
across different fields to so this isn't
this is it's all its intensive since
what is it a it's a semester crunched
into a week mmm-hmm yeah that's about
this that that's correct when we and
this this really connects to the online
course when when we saw how massive
really and the the the word massive
isn't the acronym MOOC massive open
online courses when you saw the massive
in the MOOC we realize there is
something special here and at the time I
started thinking that universities are
no longer the same and they do not just
have to be places of research and
teaching that are relatively local or
regional
at best in fact University said
innovation communities because we had
students from every country in the world
they wanted to learn but also and that's
a equally important they wanted to
collaborate and I said to myself huh
what is possible here when you can
combine knowledge that you guide people
in the process of collaboration and then
you can create links but between people
that are unprecedented because you know
previously how would an entrepreneur in
Chile work with an entrepreneur in
Vietnam and I realized that you can
build ventures and organizations that
are radically novel that excited me and
so when the the president of MIT arrived
arrived and the the head of MIT open
Learning Center charmant you who is my
mentor when they just saw the the level
of community engagement in our course
they said hey there must be something
more there too and so we decided to
organize what we ended up calling boot
camp it wasn't called the boot camp in
the very beginning we we didn't know
what to call it we just said hey there
are some really outstanding people in
this group of students online many of
them you know have not come to MIT have
not started the mighty even but we want
them to be in our community what can we
do and we organized a one-week boot camp
one week because we wanted to make it
relatively short so that very busy
people can still take the time we wanted
very busy people so they made it short
and that was a remarkable program it was
a personal discovery from nothing it
wasn't just about knowledge it was about
self-discovery these individuals came
together and they discovered their new
themselves we call it the new you they
they saw it and when you see it
something special happens in your life
yeah one week of time on a deep dive
into a subject and you can gain
potentially a semester of experience and
have your own new perspective awakened
to have a new lens on the world with
that subject matter
and then that can compound over time and
make you such a better entrepreneur or
scientist or whatever field as well
there's so many different fields that
that you guys that you guys have it's I
think what are the water the I wrote
down the upcoming ones there
well our latest one was on AI and
robotics and we explored the future of
work through AI and robotics and we held
that bootcamp in Tokyo Japan because we
want to reach a global audience but made
a decision to hold boot camps not just
here at MIT on campus but to go to
different parts of the world and they've
offered boot camps in in Japan in
Australia and in Brazil in Turkey in
Taiwan in Korea in Mexico and we're
going to be doing many more in different
parts of also we have with three coming
up two in June here in Cambridge one
will be in partnership is a Harvard
Medical School and it will be a boot
camp focused on innovation in healthcare
we will also have a boot camp in June
called the deep tech and it will be a
fast deep introduction to AI cyber
security machine learning blockchain one
very intensive work and so I think if
you want to explore the frontiers of
this technology this is a good place to
be and then we have a boot camp coming
up in September in Germany that is
focused on innovation in sports yeah so
around the world boot camps and all
these different subjects
yeah sports medicine AI cybersecurity
blockchain this is these are all such
pressing fields and it's great that
people around the world room to do it
and it's cool that MIT has created a
this this such a process that enables it
to happen and then now I want you to
explain also the micro masters that
you're also direct co-founding and
directing the this enables people to get
a
the part of their master's degree online
teachers yes so the the the micro messes
idea was conceived by sanjay sharma when
we discussed already and i i think it's
one of the most fundamental innovations
in education the underlying concept let
me first describe the underlying concept
because i think it is going to be
interesting to your community because
this is something they may want to
undertake the underlying concept is
inverted admissions and let me explain
it in in the following sense
every year thousands of people apply for
graduate school at MIT and in in many of
our departments graduate school
applications are reviewed by faculty
members right at MIT Sloan they are
reviewed by an admissions committee that
doesn't necessarily involve faculty but
in many departments graduate students
are admitted by faculty now what merit
in an application you you need to have a
good recommendation right that you have
promised to do excellent research and
that that's what graduate school is for
or you have promised to do excellent
professional work of the highest caliber
that integrates new knowledge into
professions and creates new professions
you have to have excellent grades but by
virtue of the fact that people apply
from all over the world
the majority of people who apply apply
from schools and have recommendations
from people that the MIT faculty members
do not know right why did a problem
context is important and it is often
challenging for many faculty members to
know this is a good school how do I know
that great in this school worse the
master how do I know that the
recommendation submitted is a
recommendation that was treated with the
greatest rigor that we expect at MIT
very hard to know that right
inverted admissions takes a problem out
of the question
it gives you an opportunity to show what
you can do you can take a number of MIT
courses online if you do well and you
take a proctored exam and again you do
it online but we verify that it's you if
you take it if you take it and you do it
well you have a chance to apply for a
master's program at MIT and if you get
in your online credential we call them
micro masters and it's a substantial
credential it is equivalent to a
semester of course work at MIT right so
it's it is serious amount of work that
credit gets counted and so you can
graduate twice as fast and twice as
inexpensively big difference and now we
have the first cohorts of students who
came from the micro masters to the
master's program at MIT and all of the
faculty members who work with them say
they're outstanding
yeah you have a know this is another
filtration mechanism of there's so many
applicants from around the world how do
you make it so that you think in prove
that they're capable of handling the
rigor of the MIT graduate coursework and
you built a system that enables you to
funnel the most optimal yeah you
identified it correctly exactly the goal
in admissions is to understand can the
person handle the rigor of work here
right because we don't want to fail
students that's not a that's that's not
a great thing to do that that's not it
successful for anyone right so you want
to bring people here who will do well
and take the best advantage of of being
here but how do you know now when the
individual has gone through a sequence
of rigorous coursework online showed
real persistence in fact persistence
that is far greater than the persistence
you need on campus because normally you
are taking the online courses while
you're studying in another school or
working for a company right it takes
some motivation persistence to be able
to do it then we know that you will do
well here and the micro master students
do
and that hit inverted in missions as
well which is a very interesting concept
and then the incubation group as well
can you explain that very happy to do it
again the incubation group was a
conception of fast sanjay sharma and he
actually hired me into the incubation
group and there it is simple can we
create a group that will generate new
initiatives the the mooc was the result
of the incubation group the boot camp
was a result of the incubation group and
as soon as a new initiative attains its
likes we stand it up as its own
independent entity within the umbrella
of the organization here and so it's
it's a process of creating new
initiatives creating sustainable
foundations for them and stimulating
continuous innovation and then this is
now going from just a university to a
global innovation community I love your
your tagline of decreasing making it so
there's no barriers between motivation
and opportunity worldwide let's unpack a
little bit about these new pathways
apprenticeships versus internships teach
us about the very happy to do that so
you know here here at MIT open learning
we want to imagine a new world of
education and professional
accomplishment one of the one of the
challenges for us here is historically
the world of education and the world of
Industry have been somewhat delinked
right education was about the pursuit of
truth and that is very important asking
questions and Industry about creating
value now we see increasingly they need
to integrate the two worlds why and
that's because people's professional
lives become longer right therefore you
have to continue updating your knowledge
and we also see that people have to
engage in many more fields of activity
and so exposure to education is is
essential throughout a person's life and
actually even though I do have two
masters degrees I do think it's quite
possible that
I will go back to school at some point
in the future I do think this is
possible probably it won't happen in a
traditional sense but this is going to
be essential for me especially with the
augmented reality spatial computing and
right now so much easier too and I think
this is this is actually the year where
augmented reality is actually showing
real science of making impact on the
world of Education we've we've had some
very interesting breakthroughs and I
might you that I'm excited about but you
know now we need to take the two worlds
that have been somewhat distinct and we
need to integrate them so that people
are more successful and if they're more
successful they're happy and that's just
that's just a good thing so that is why
we're creating new pathways we're
integrating online coursework were
integrating online credentials we're
integrating online boot camps and now
we're also focused on apprenticeships
what we want we have this this is so
crucial because of bloom to Sigma
especially you'll perform two standard
deviations so past the mean if you have
a one-on-one mentorship really yeah it's
so crazy
so psychologists have been studying it
on it's just fascinating phenomenon so
another almost everyone that we sit with
on the show has had mentors that have
just vastly helped them on an upward
trajectory so this is great these
apprenticeships yeah oh it's uh it's not
surprising I would love a link is this
is of interest to me so I think after
after the show you could send it to me
when you get a chance but yes we want
someone to go through a rigorous set of
online courses with us get a credential
go through a boot camp get a credential
and then we want to create an
apprenticeship opportunity and have the
person go spend three to six months at
the United Nations and you know perhaps
FIFA and a start-up at
advisor at at a university being an
apprentice to two person who is on the
cutting edge and and that in its own
right then becomes a credential - and
your pathway to a new opportunity in in
your vocation you can stamp that I came
and worked under you for three to six
months at open learning and that's on
potentially on a decentralized ledger as
well and then everyone can see that I've
gained that rabirius yeah yeah all right
that's right and I think to do to your
point that you made before we begin
that's what makes apprenticeships
different from internships you know an
apprenticeships is very focused and it
comes with a credential and that
credential is a hybrid educational and
professional credential yeah this this
this of funneling of of taking online
democratizing online learning and then
taking people that really want to gain
further credentials through the system
all the way up into the physical
one-on-one apprenticeship world is very
beautiful and I think we've up to this
eight billion population we're going to
is we've kind of lost a little bit of
that one-on-one apprenticeship and also
being able to log that as something that
is that is a major credential and I
really look forward to that rising back
up into our world and and yeah that's so
critical getting an experience in the
real world yeah I'm very hopeful of that
I'm very hopeful that I think as soon as
we begin thinking beyond the constraints
of the current environment and how
universities are constructed today we
would stand a good shot at creating a
new system that is far better yeah an
open learnings totally at the edge let's
do the two quick questions on the way
out first question is are we in a
simulation well that's a deeper question
that that's really
a deep question that's a that's actually
a deep question was very very big
consequences for philosophy for sure
and possibly for for action no I don't
believe so I don't believe so and you
know and and my answer to you stems from
from my children when when I see when I
when I see my children I have five three
kids I have a daughter Maria who is
seven daughter Lily who is four and son
Daniel who is two when I see them and I
see their their eternal beauty you know
and the beauty of the eternal beauty of
that moment when when your child smiles
was the most sincere vibrant megawatt
smile I just you know I just don't think
that there is a chance that that could
have been simulated yeah
and then to think about your children
also and the way that they'll be using
the exponential technologies today that
you know we didn't have growing up to
learn the way that their mind is going
to understand reality as well is going
to be profoundly augmented compared to
yeah how we grew up yeah yeah yeah that
that's possible yeah I have a very very
strong feeling and faith and and and
they're taking on the world's biggest
challenges you got three of them yeah
molding minds into the world and
exponential technology age is
interesting too and the last question is
what is the most beautiful thing in the
world
oh they the smile of a child tell us why
others there's no feeling like it when
you see it there's just I I've not had a
better more beautiful you know more
light feeling ever
yeah it's just it almost defies
explanation
it's a smile of a child a smile of a
child yeah yeah thank you so much for
coming onto the show you know you're
most welcome thank you I appreciate you
doing this and I think it's wonderful
that you are reaching so many people
with new ideas you're making really big
dinner thank you we're very grateful for
that and we're very grateful for your
work and the work of the MIT is open
learning everyone please check out mi
t--'s open learning community check out
all the links in the bio below to do
that
and go and share the content with other
people around the world about how we can
get the the eradicate the barriers
between motivation and opportunity what
a profound statement and also support
the artists and entrepreneurs and
organizations around the world that you
believe in support simulation our links
are below also go and build the future
manifest your dreams into the world
everyone thank you so much for tuning in
and we will see you soon peace that's it
Rd great you are great job you are great
hey I have a long way to go brother I
have a long way to go